[Music]
We solved four sums in the previous two
parts and got the following
answers 0.3 with a b over 3 as
3/9
0.75 with the b over 5 a 68 ba 90 and 0.35 2
with the b o 352 s 352 ba
999 and  The last one was
0239 4 with the ba over 94 s
2371 ba
9900 vs we did convert the decimals
to the rational number form p ba q but the
procedure we used was very long and aa we made it
time [ __ ] and boring let's
look at  A Shortcut Another Way to Solve It
First Let's Classify the Decimal
Numbers Into Simple and Mixed Recurring
Decimal Numbers The first decimal is simple since all the digits after the decimal
point are repeated even This
number is simple since
352 is repeated after the decimal point
Are Also Called Pure Recurring Decimals
In the second example the bar lies now the number
five and the digit sen is not repeated so it is
a mixed recurring decimal in this example only
94 is repeated and not since
it is a mixed decimal two now let's
focus  On Simple Decimals Do Not Look at the
Answer for Now The Denominator of the Fraction Will Have
as Many Nine as the Number of Recurring
Digits Here We Have Just One Digit that is
Recurring It's Three So the Denominator Will Be Na
and Finding the Numeration Is  Even More
Simple We Write the Number Without the Decimal and
the Bar It Will Be Three Ts It Gives Your Answer
No Equations No Subject No Variables Nothing Let's
Understand It With Another Simple
Recurring Decimal the Denominator will contain as many as
the number of recurring digits here
We have three recurring digits 3 5 2 So we will have
999 in the denominator and the
numeration without the decimal and the bar
352 That's it
and the numeration is written without the
decimal point and the bar Now let's get to
mixed recurring decimals This is a little
Tricky But Very Interesting Again The
Denominator Counts As Many Nines As The Number
Of Recurring Digits Here We Have Only One
Digit That Is Recurring It's Five So We Write A
Nine In The Denominator But Wait We're Not Done
With The Denominator We Write As Many Zeros
As  The Number of Non Recurring Digits We Have
One Non Recurring Digit Here It's Sen So We
Write One Zero Here's Our Denominator What About
The
Numeration Number Is Se So We
Subs That Gives Us An Answer Of 68 By 90
Remember The Only Difference Here Is The  Zero for
the non recurring digits and the subtraction of
the non recurring number Let's try it out
with this number now it has two digits which are recurring
so we write a 99 in the denominator and there are two
digits which are non recurring so we
write  A 0 0 Next to 99 in the new we
write the number without the decimal or the bar and then we subtract
the non recurring number
viz 23 that gives us the answer as
2371 by
9900 so these simple steps give you the answer
in  Like 10 Seconds Don't Worry About The
Rules They Are Mentioned In The Summary Section But Here's
An Interesting Question
Answers Like 0 P Something What If We Have A
Number Like 2.3 With A B Other It's Simple We
Just Write It As 2 + 0.3 B V  Knowing how to
write 0.3 times in the p/q form we take a
scratch paper and use our technique to write
0.3 times in the p/q form since it is a
simple recurring decimal and we have just one
digit which is recurring we write the
denominator  As nine as many nines as the
number of recurring
digits and the numeration is the number without
a decimal and the times 3 this can be
reduced to
1/3 so this can be written as 2+ 1/3 that is 2
1/3  In mixed fraction form and 7/3 in the
p ba k
[music]
form